every third day i'm getting five texts
from our cast and crew going oh my god
this scene from the movie just happened
this scene from the movie just happened
and so
i had a moment where i was like do we
need to make this movie has it just
happened and it was very strange because
netflix about five months into the
quarantine let us know that they think
they have a way to do it safe
and i was still wondering like did our
movie just come true
[Music]
adam i was delighted to be able to go
and see don't look up on the big screen
recently it really is a big screen
experience i'm a huge admirer of all
your work but i think this is this is
something particularly extraordinary how
did it come about
you know i think it came to me uh from
the place that a lot of good ideas come
from which is stark terror it was about
three
maybe four years ago
and this has been building for 10 or 12
years where
the climate crisis just keeps
everything i learned about it just seems
worse and worse and that un report from
the ipcc came out and
i couldn't sleep for three nights after
i read it and i just like i have to
do something about this
and luckily a friend of mine made a joke
about it's like climate change is like a
comet's going to hit earth and no one
cares and
that's the idea that's david sirota who
shares a
story by credit with me
but and i like the fact that we got to
laugh you know because i i think it's
very easy with some of this stuff to
just go down a doom hole but i i thought
it was really important that we laughed
that we're able to look at ourselves and
little did i know at the time that i
wrote it you know once every 200 years
pandemic was headed towards us so
it's been a very strange experience let
me ask you how did you come upon
cyrano because i i i believe it was a
stage production first is that the case
i had always loved the story of cyrano
being a kind of dweeby
unlovable teenager who you know thought
himself completely unworthy of affection
when i saw the gerard dapadio version i
was like oh that's me but there was no
real reason to
make another version of it until i saw a
tiny little workshop at the chester
theatre in connecticut it was a like 120
seater and peter dinklage was playing
cyrano and hayley bennett was playing
roxanne and seeing
them play those roles suddenly opened up
the possibility for me of doing a
musical version with them in those
central roles because it felt totally
fresh and modern and intimate and it had
a kind of level of intimate authenticity
that really excited me first i asked
haley if i could approach he and erica
schmidt who wrote the stage version and
she agreed so i approached them and they
agreed and so we started developing
the film uh over you know two or three
years and then we were in a pandemic and
and suddenly
it felt now is the right time to make a
film about
human connection and the
difficulty in
connecting with other people and the
difficulty of allowing yourself to be
seen so that was the genesis of it my
sole purpose on this earth is to love
roxanne does she know the world will
never accept someone like me and a tall
beautiful woman
someone told me this was a
three-year process because
we did don't look up it was pretty crazy
it was over two years obviously with
having new stop production or we were
scouting when we shut down for the
pandemic
and so probably all told with the
writing of the script it was two two and
a half years but i heard you guys is
that true that you guys were three years
no we were developing the script for
three years and then it was
june 28 2020 so we'd been in lockdown
for about four months in the uk
when i felt like i got the script to
the right place and i just had to go out
and make a movie i was going out of my
mind so i called i called eric felner
and he said you've got five percent
chance of getting this made so i said
great that's enough for me and we
managed to
raise the money from mgm and we went and
shot in the middle of the pandemic which
felt like we were on a mission like a
mission of love and human connection you
know the uk government was very very
slow in
getting money together for the arts for
freelance crafts and arts people
and so it was a way of getting food on
the table for them and also a way of us
all connecting together and then
connecting for for an audience and so
you shot during the pandemic
we did the same thing yeah we
we shut down in the middle of scouting
in march when it all hit
and then i went home for like all of us
did for
what five months
and
in our case it was really strange
because you know you've seen the movie
you know the premise
a lot of it is a lot like kovid
and so
every third day i'm getting five texts
from our cast and crew going oh my god
this scene from the movie just happened
this scene from the movie just happened
and so
i had a moment where i was like do we
need to make this movie has it just
happened and it was very strange because
netflix about five months into the
quarantine let us know that they think
they have a way to do it safe
and i was still wondering like did did
our movie just come true and i picked it
up and i read it
and i realized it read in a completely
different way that the movie was never
about coveted or climate change although
to some degree it's still about climate
change but
that it was really all about how we
broken
the means we prophetized and distorted
the means with which we talk to each
other and communicate so it was it was
really always about social media
careerism and greed and that it was
always about that and it was a great
experience because we were more excited
to then charge into it and we have
similar experience that you did which is
you know the testing the masks the zones
the all that kind of stuff
and everyone had the same attitude that
you were just talking about which is we
were so
grateful that we were able to make the
movie
and to able to process feelings and do
what we do
so even though we had to go home to you
know our solo empty apartments at night
the fact that we were able to
play with each other and do these scenes
and
you know improvise and laugh was just
we felt we felt spoiled even though it
was really really bizarre i'm curious
with you though the guy and how did you
deal with this because
i know how we dealt with it but you have
scenes in this movie
uh one of the opening scenes that the
theater is really packed well the
theater scene we were had you know we
had a limited number of extras we were
allowed to use it was only like 160
people it was our maximum number and so
we designed the set so that it looked
full so we basically reduced the size of
the set to to make it feel packed
we built the set outdoors we had a
location which was an interior theater
but then we kind of changed that so that
we could kind of refer to theater of the
light
early 18th century
uh which was often outdoors so that you
got the kind of aeration and also my mum
who's a puppet maker and prop maker
made 160 leather masks in the kind of
comedy de lata style
um so a lot of the extras in the
background are actually wearing masks
but they're just kind of on camera masks
and we did a little important they were
wearing the kind of cyrano nose
so we ki and then we tested everybody
every day you know and because the town
had pretty much closed down by that
point
all of the extras were going home
isolating coming to work and it was you
know it was a bigger number but it was
the same
the same idea one of the things i really
love about what you do and and and also
kind of political satire is that it does
help me process my feelings through
laughter which uh i find to be a really
healthy way of i mean i think that's the
probably the the point of laughter
is that it allows us to look at really
scary dark things and not hide from them
but see them in a way that i can
actually take if i see a film about the
climate crisis that's a drama you know
i'm i'm i'm in bits on the floor but
with your movie i'm able to laugh at it
and
that doesn't mean i kind of can forget
it i i take it all in
but the way i've digested it through
laughter means that it's it's
it's possible to do that the same
applied to dr strangelove i was always
terrified of the nuclear bomb when i saw
that film it allowed me to process those
feelings but what i love it also is that
it works you know it's it's it works in
the macro but also in the micro um one
of my favorite things in the whole movie
is is jennifer lawrence's obsession with
this character who charged for the
snacks
which seemed to satisfies both the greed
of the guy who's charging for the snacks
but also satirizes our own kind of ocd
obsession with the finer details and i
think that often political satire works
on the big level but not necessarily the
details whereas you managed to the
details are so kind of perfect i know
you come from
an improvisational background
how much of the script is improvised how
much freedom is there for the actors in
that sense you know i i i give the
actors total freedom i i jokingly call
myself the anti-david mammon
i sort of hope and pray they'll mess
around with what i've written
i mean
also when we're filming i always say
like we get the scripted i always say we
fulfilled our legal obligation we've
gotten the script and we want the
scripted to be good
and usually what it ends up being
depending on the movie i mean the early
stuff i did with will ferro i think the
amount of improv in those movies could
get as high as 25
i would say with a movie like this it's
you know it's 10 15
it's what and what i love about it and
and correct me if i'm wrong but you come
from a theater family or theater
background as well so you know this when
the playfulness is introduced
even the acting with the scripted gets
better yeah the actors feel freer
because even when you're doing a
scripted material there's always improv
even involved in that so
i i love creating that environment and i
let the actors know
that the whole way the improv works is
some of it's not going to be good and we
want the stuff that's not great like the
stuff that's not great gets us to the
good stuff
and so we really try and create an
environment where it's playful
the judgment is relatively low you can
mess up you can swing and miss and i
think you're right i think with this
movie the laughter is a big part of it
but at the same time and your movie has
this too where you could feel a lot of
different things at the same time and i
i think because of how commodified our
society has become
people tend to think that it's either
sad or happy or you're laughing
and you know in your movie i was
feeling the emotion of the music i was
laughing i was having a good time i was
feeling
really stricken at certain points and
and i think it's okay for
all of those emotions to exist on the
same uh lazy susan if you will and so
with our movie we really tried to do
that we wanted people to laugh hard
because i agree with you i think
laughter right away means you have
perspective you're not overwhelmed i
think in order to laugh
you have to have some distance so
we were really kind of playing around
with that collage of feelings we're all
feeling in this
insane fun house mirror reality that
we're living in at this exact moment i
say we sit tight and assess
sit tight and assess sit tight and then
assess
i gotta ask you the big question the
million-dollar question is
how when did you know or was it in the
original theatrical production
that there would be no no's you would
never because that's
for most people when they think of
cyrano i'm assuming it was in the
theatrical production there was no it
was yeah in the theatrical production
there was no nose and
in a way the idea
was that the nose would distract from
the reality that we can all share
which is that we all feel at certain
points if not you know continuously
unworthy of love so it's an inside job
it's you know it's not his nose it's not
pete's height the point is is that he
feels emotionally that he will never be
able to be loved by the person that he
loves and hopefully that makes it more
immediate
and more relatable because the idea for
me is always to
kind of make films that help me unpack
my own feelings about stuff
and i do that through
period movies which are kind of
fantasies rather than period because of
my parents running a puppet theater i
was brought up on fairy tales and i see
them as being
a way of reflecting back on us our own
psychology without the details and
ephemera of perceived kind of
contemporary reality so they're all kind
of fantasies i think the
period movies are often considered to be
kind of um
conservative or reactionary and what
i've tried to do throughout my career is
to kind of subvert that really and to
try and subvert the the genre as as a
whole i love the point you just made
about how you like period movies because
they're close to fairy tales and they
free us from the
you know constrictions of of reality i
think that's really interesting i i and
you know what i love about it too and i
saw this in your movie is that because
the culture and the mores of the times
are always a little different it's funny
i mean you could go back 2 000 years ago
and it's not as different i mean when
they were building the pyramids they
were drinking beer and they were
laughing and
they had social hierarchy a hundred
percent it's a lot less different than
you think yeah but there's always a
couple things that are different
and and i love seeing that in your your
opening scene where one of the members
of the duke's entourage challenges
cyrano
he challenges him because he's not
wearing feathers and he's not dressed in
the in the appropriate way so i i really
enjoy and i think the way you do a great
job of it the way you use period
because of the little differences that
point out the commonalities even though
it looks and feels so
different anyway i i that's a really
interesting thing exactly that's exactly
what i'm i'm trying to trying to do you
know when i started out i really wanted
to make gritty british realist drama
about the oppressed working classes and
i just wasn't very good at it
you know there were people who were much
much better at it than me
and then i got asked to make pride and
prejudice and i was like what are you
talking about i don't wanna you know
that's crazy i'm i'm tough and i'm you
know but when i made that movie i found
that i just loved it i loved the whole
process of it and i felt very at home in
it and it felt very natural and so i
guess the point being is your career is
what happens whilst you're busy making
other plans or developing other scripts
and now i'm accepting of it you know
i've reached a certain age where i go
okay this is all right this is this is
me it's okay rather than trying to be
different all the time and trying to be
cool you know
it's so true you were talking about the
improv i mean there's no question that
you know i come from a i come from a
theater improvisational background as
well
and i've always loved comedy i mean i've
always been engaged in politics and i
have a lot of different interests and i
love a lot of different kinds of movies
the same thing happened to me where i
was just like oh i'm gonna make movies
and have the greatest job in the world
where i get to laugh all day long and
then all of a sudden someone shook the
world like a snow globe and it was like
all right uh
that no longer makes sense let's adjust
a little bit here oh by the way to
answer your question about the improv um
one of my favorite moments in the movie
completely improvised from jonah hill he
does a prayer
as we're about to launch the rest
and it's not a prayer for people or fans
of practice
[Laughter]
and you you probably dealt with this
when the improv is really good yeah
incorporated into the coverage you then
go i need a single of that i need a
media
and i told you i go okay that's in the
coverage we're getting that one that's
your day but it's worth it
oh it's the best it's the best it's it's
it's so great because you get the
scripted you know they're amazing actors
and
everyone's incredible so the script is
beautiful and then
you know you have to balance that
schedule so you're not up against it but
if you've got that little bit of time
it's just there's no risk and you you
just end up with these gems so how
certain is this 99.78
to be exact oh great okay so it's not
100 call it 70 and let's just let's move
on the big shock for me and did you know
that like meryl streep is an absolute
killer improviser i did not know that
and i'm not exaggerating i'm not being
like
nice hollywood director pray like i'm
saying this to you straight up one of
the great improvisers i have ever met or
seen pitch perfect real
and most of all she can do 20 takes
where every improv is different
and i kept asking her i'm like what
did you study improvisation like and she
would never give me a straight answer
she was just always like oh you know i'm
just having fun i'm like and then jonah
and i would talk and jonah is a
magnificent improviser
and even he was like dude i i did not
know this was the case um
so little little secret uh in the future
if you're if you're blessed enough to be
in that situation uh she is an
absolute assassin when it comes to
improv
did you have those actors in mind as he
was writing it yeah a bunch of them i
originally wrote kate dibioski who's the
doctoral candidate grad student that was
written for jen lawrence right from the
jump teddy oglethorpe who's the
government nasa official
was written for rob morgan and then when
i wrote the president
i did the delusional thing of like maybe
we could get meryl streep assuming that
would not happen so that was the crazy
big swing where i when she said yes i
couldn't believe it and i was sort of
thinking of cate blanchett for briavante
and a couple other names i remember when
i worked on hannah with kate and on the
first couple of days i was a little bit
intimidated and so i employed a usual
trick which was to ask people i'm
intimidated by
about their childhood and about their
schooling and so on and i discovered
that kate was a head girl at her school
and then it all just made sense and i
was like oh okay you're a head girl and
there's an element of her head girl
nuss that comes out and this and i love
that scene in the bed when they feel
like they have to do the getting to know
you stuff and the only kind of
information exposition backstory really
she offers is that she slept with two
ex-presidents
you're gonna go oh i know exactly who
this person is i don't need i don't need
a monologue i don't need like
you know two pages of my parents this
that the other whatever she slept with
two ex-presidents i know who you are
that's it you got it it's a brilliant
piece of writing oh thanks man i i gotta
ask you the million-dollar question
which be on the nose which is the kind
of first thought question which is so i
have shot a bunch of musical scenes in
my movies and about half of them have
been cut
to the point where it's a joke among the
people i work with that like mckay
you want to do a musical i've gotten a
couple of them in there's a musical
sequence in this movie
anchorman has one uh stepbrothers
[Music]
but i've had a couple doozies that were
like two days of filming and i
was like it doesn't work so i i'm so
curious because the musical numbers in
this are are just fantastic and they
feel intimate and they pull me in and
they ride right on the story what what
was your approach uh going into a
musical number is there is there
anything different that you do because
everyone does musical numbers
differently some people
have to have it be live on the set some
people shoot it in wide it's like i'm
just curious how you approach because
it's so well done
i guess what i didn't want to do was
have the kind of needle drop you know
talking talking talking and then
suddenly
uh we start singing and it's a
completely different movie i wanted a
sense of naturalism to the songs i was
listening to some music one day and i
was singing along at home you know and i
thought oh that's what it should be like
it should be like you're just singing
along to something that's playing
in the background and that feels very
natural you don't even you know think
about it so to that end we did record
all the singing live which
brought an intimacy as you say in a kind
of authenticity but it allowed for
faults and i really like the faults and
stuff you know i don't want my films to
be
shiny shiny perfect perfect because i
don't recognize myself in that i feel
at home in slightly messy environments i
want my films to be messy because life
is messy and so
recording all the singing live on camera
meant that there are faults there are
cracks in the voices there are breaths
taken at the wrong moment there's one
point haley bennett kind of wells up and
almost cries which inhibits her ability
to sing
which was important to me i wanted those
kind of human
fallibilities because it's a film about
human fallibility and it's about how
we're all a little bit broken you know
and that that's okay accepting of those
accepting of those ideas
and cry for
and i won't be ashamed
i think one of the interesting things
about musical numbers is that they're a
bit like fights in the sense that you
have to be very very clear about your
endpoints and your out points and they
have to have a very definite structure
you can't just kind of see how it goes
so
trying to get a kind of very
naturalistic observational feeling um at
the same time as having them very very
structured was
uh an interesting uh an interesting
challenge my editor hank corwin and i
started talking about how
there's always another character in the
room which is this media churn
white noise buzz which depending on
which country you're in can be very loud
in the u.s obviously it's deafening that
social media broadcast all that kind of
stuff
and how much more and more as the years
go by it's shaping our discussion and
it's becoming part of our life so with
the big short we talked about how can we
make that part of the movie and we ended
up using some stock footage and we ended
up going through it
so then with vice i said you know what
i'm going to shoot our own stock footage
so what we would do is when we would
have a location like the white house for
instance and don't look up
i would put on the schedule
that we're going to literally step
outside the sound stage with a cell
phone camera and i need a wall and i
need two extras
and or i'm going to use a super 8 or i'm
going to use whatever or security cam
footage and
so
our god bless our line producer ep jeff
waxman um he just got used to it that
everywhere we went we were always
getting three extra shots that would be
quote stock footage so what you end up
seeing in the movie is like you know
half the footage maybe even 60 percent
is fake stock footage that we made and
my editor hank corwin just pours through
it
uh looks at everything hundreds and
hundreds of shots to get that exact
right rhythm he's he's really a maniac
about it very much a hero of your movie
he's i mean hank curran is is incredible
it's a beautifully cut movie and it
always means that we're into cut um
you know in the kind of non-linear
moments when you're cutting forward in
time and back in time and so on in a
kind of nick rogue almost sense were
they scripted like that or was that
something that just developed through
the through post
once again so this is my third film with
the hank corwin and there's really no
one like him so it's funny i now script
my scripts with flash for you know this
scene where they're in the oval office
and we're cutting to the battleship with
their speech it was actually written
that way
and it was funny because hank was like
that really works i was like yeah
because i wrote it i wrote it because i
knew that's how you cut it and
that's great so it's really great i mean
even unusual relationship with hank
corwin and my composer nick patel
the three of us really start talking
about these movies very early on those
two guys had very hard jobs on this
movie i mean to find the music that can
capture that what what bertel did just
blew me away and and corwin too had to
const with a lot of little tweaks and
shaping and that movie's at that moment
is a little too ridiculous we need a
little more you know this could be more
ridiculous so yeah i agree with you hank
corwin and our composer nick patel i
really love having uh music composed
prior to shooting what's the best i
actually think i'm curious what you
think about this i think
because of the over saturation of media
because of social media it takes out all
this stuff
i'm kind of curious to see if there's a
theater is always a powerful force but
i'm curious to see if there's a
renaissance of live intimate chamber
theater because
to me it seems more powerful than ever
the idea of being it has been there has
been in london up and up before the
pandemic it was happening and it was it
was really exciting and i was probably
going to see more theater at the time
than i was film
uh because of the immediacy of it you
know the pandemic kibosh that and
hopefully all hopefully it will
re-emerge though because it's important
and people get it's much cheaper and so
people get to put on
stories that are more urgent to them you
know
yeah
well i think it's the barrier of entry i
mean it's the reason that
a lot of the internet and tick tock and
all youtube are so popular is because
back when i was in my 20s i wanted to do
comedy i wanted to do sketch
you had to in the states you had to go
to chicago that's where second city was
that's where live theater so there was
this crazy migration
of these just amazing like tina fey
chris farley tim meadows mike myers all
these people
showed up in this city and
and i i'll be eternally thankful for
that that community that i got to be a
part of that
and i i am curious to see if it comes
back i i love hearing that you're saying
there was some of that going on before
the pandemic that's very exciting and it
sounds like your movie came
from a live theater event that wasn't in
a
1800
no not at all it came from
a workshop you know it came from an
experimental workshop and and
and so that gave me space to
fill in with my own imagination the the
spaces that had been left and that was
really exciting but i i always
i always remember my dad once uh
someone calling to book tickets for the
puppet theater saying
uh is there any audience participation
involved in the show because
we don't like audience participation
and my dad said yes madam there is there
is the participation of the imagination
and i think that has stuck with me and i
think that's more possible in theater
but what one's trying to do is to bring
that to film as well that's what i was
trying to do with anna karenina and
that's you know not filling in every
detail of the screen with reality but
allowing space for the audience to
project their own imaginations and their
own feelings and i think what you
uh have done with the editing and the
writing of don't look up is that you
allow space for the audience to make
connections between these disparate
images and it's the space between the
images which is is as exciting as the
images themselves if you like and those
very hard cuts you do you know there's a
brilliant hard cut when leo is making
this kind of speech on tv and he's going
into this complete breakdown moment and
then you cut in the middle of a sentence
if not a word
and and for me that
means that the audience is required to
participate it's not a passive
experience and and i've always wanted to
try and
get audiences to participate actively
rather than just have this kind of dead
you know passive thing of being fed
truisms or bland stuff you know it's
it's important that we get people to to
also realizes realize that there are
choices to make in life what you're
describing just in the abstract is
that's my favorite all the magical
experiences
i've had in theaters i've had at live
music watching a movie
are the ones where you can feel it
become something that's bigger than just
the stage where you feel like you're a
part of it i want to see uh the adam
mckay musical
um
i i want to see
uh i want to see it all adam i can't
wait to to keep watching all your stuff
uh because you make it all
feel
a little bit better bless you i i gotta
tell you
i i love what you're doing with period
i wanna see you keep going at that
i'd love to see you do a movie that
takes place in
320 bce
i want to see you do one that's
just you know there's not even human
being i i just i love what you're doing
with finding the commonality the
universal
in in this experience of living and uh
and then on another level i just thought
your movie was i just had a blast
watching it i thought it was beautiful
looking and love the characters so
there's that level and then there's the
bigger thing but i i feel the same way
i'm just a a huge fan of your work and
and what a pleasure to to finally meet
you granted
three screens but uh i understand you're
probably just up the road so do you want
to go for a coffee now
if you turn around i'm right behind you
[Music]
you